i'd like to share with you um the
potential underlying cause
for an overactive bladder a leaky
bladder a bladder that can't hold urine
a bladder that causes you to go more
frequently and sometimes even frequent
urination at night
so let's go ahead and dissect this
problem because there's a lot of
confusions about the underlying cause
okay and of course the treatments have
side effects
but
many of the medications that they use
for this condition are
anti-cholinergic now what does that mean
it means that they block a certain
neurotransmitter called acetylcholine
now acetylcholine is kind of like a um
a hormone within the nervous system
that
affects the pelvic floor
as well as the mechanisms that allow you
to
contract and relax your bladder and that
whole system collectively is called the
autonomic nervous system so the drugs
that they use for leaky bladder really
are affecting the autonomic nervous
system which makes sense because one of
the
root dysfunctions is neurogenic which
means it's coming from the nervous
system the other cause that they talk
about is idiopathic
that is a fancy term that means unknown
cause okay and what we do know about the
idiopathic or unknown causes of a leaky
bladder is that a major cause for that
is
you guessed it insulin resistance okay
that's a condition where you also have
high amounts of
insulin which then leads to alteration
within your autonomic nervous system so
when you have this imbalance or
dysfunction within the sympathetic
nervous system and the parasympathetic
can affect the muscle called the
detrusor muscle so now the confusing
part about this when you do research on
it
they pretty much
focus in on estrogen okay a loss of
estrogen especially after menopause
because of course when you go through
menopause
your estrogen drops so you definitely
have a hormonal
problem that can definitely affect
the
bladder as well as the vaginal area and
many other parts of the body but the
problem is when you give someone with a
leaky bladder estrogen it doesn't seem
to solve the problem it's more of a
nerve related problem within the
autonomic nervous system which can be
greatly affected when you have
insulin resistance so this problem gets
worse when you age when you're pregnant
uh when you have childbirth especially
multiple childbirths because that's
going to affect those muscles that help
you contract and relax
because that's going to affect the
structure it's going to
stretch out uh the valve that controls
um the release of urine through your
bladder and then also there's things
that aggravate it like
chronic constipation
uh obesity problems with chronic
coughing and asthma and of course the
usual stuff
people that drink a lot of tea and
coffee these things can all aggravate
the condition not to mention this
condition getting worse when you're
under stress which makes a lot of sense
because
of how stress influences the autonomic
nervous system so the first thing i'm
going to recommend is something that
might just solve it without having to
even try any herbal remedies or even the
kegel exercises and that would be
addressing this insulin resistance
insulin resistance
dramatically and negatively affects the
autonomic nervous system so a lot of
problems connected to that will
disappear when you address this insulin
resistance i'm going to recommend
healthy keto and intermittent fasting
and really do it
for real where you're eliminating these
refined carbs you're keeping your carbs
under i would say 25 grams per day
you're doing the healthy version of the
ketogenic diet as well as doing
intermittent fasting so you're fasting
for 18 hours
and you have an eating window of six
hours so that will help frequent
urination especially in men at night
it's very very effective for that and if
your problem really is the autonomic
nervous system you're going to greatly
affect
positively the function of your bladder
control because and the reason i'm
saying this is because if you jump right
to the herbs the remedy and you don't
fix this foundational eating problem
and you don't fix insulin resistance the
herbs may not nearly have the impact
that they should and you might just kind
of chalk it up to well another remedy
didn't work
let me go for the medications the
problem is they create side effects so i
would highly recommend starting with the
healthy version of the ketogenic diet
within a minute of fasting okay that's
number one number two kegel exercises
okay now this will help put more control
into your bladder because urination is
both involuntary and voluntary and if
you start to do these exercises you
start to put more control
into the voluntary part of those muscles
how do you do that well number one you
ensure that your bladder is empty
you want to land your back maybe on your
bed okay with your knees up you want to
keep your lower back curve so you don't
want to flatten the curve in your lower
back you can even roll up a towel and
put that in your lower back but that way
it rocks your pelvis forward then you
want to lift and squeeze
the pelvic opening okay and you're gonna
do that for a count of five seconds okay
you're gonna contract those muscles and
then you're gonna relax those muscles
for five seconds and you're gonna go
back and forth for about 10 times okay
and then just do this three times a day
spread out through the day and these
exercises have been done for many years
and with a very positive effect as far
as the herbal remedies there's some
great data that i found
searching for patents using herbal or
natural remedies for an overactive
bladder and i'm going to share all this
information in the description as well
one of these patents
actually has a very hard core
study that was double-blinded placebo
control and it showed significant
improvements and i did a deep dive on
these three herbs and guess what i found
they affect the autonomic nervous system
surprise so the first herb is called
cretiva
nirvala stem bark and another name for
this is varuna number two horsetail and
number three lindura agrigata so i'll
put these three herbs in the description
so you can do your research and try to
find maybe a product that has all three
but definitely start with the healthy
version of keto within a minute of
fasting and i'm going to put a link down
below if you're new to keto
i have a just a free download you can go
to my site just download it and it'll
tell you exactly how to do this in fact
why don't i just show you a video how to
do it right here check it out